everyone I'm a be sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen so a lot of you guys have
asked me on my youtube channel and my
Instagram account what do I feed baby II
and specifically I think a lot of you
are looking for snack ideas and I think
snacks are really important both for you
know us as adults but also for babies
and toddlers because they need to kind
of eat frequently throughout the day and
I try really hard to think of my snacks
more like mini meals than necessarily
like treats I think a lot of us in our
society we reacquaint snacks with treats
but all of the recipes that I'm going to
share with you today are super simple
they're easy for you to pack up and take
with you on the go
they are low mess very important but
they're also nutrient and depth so let's
do this first up are my iron rich baby
protein pancakes to a food processor I
combined some iron fortified grain
cereal I then add some oat flour cottage
cheese for protein mashed banana natural
peanut butter eggs baking powder and
cinnamon
fold in some blueberries and then I pan
fry until golden brown next are these
avocados salmon sandwiches I start by
mashing together at an avocado with a
can of no salt salmon and a little dill
and then spreading it onto whole-grain
bread
assemble the sandwiches and come to
fingers and then serve next let's make a
quick baby friendly snack mix that's
perfect for practicing pincer grasp I
mix together some quinoa puffs some
freeze-dried fruits and vegies snacks
and then finally I'll add in a handful
of whole grain cereal give it a mix and
serve
and finally it will make some homemade
hummus to a food processor I puree some
tahini water olive oil cumin garlic
lemon juice and no salt out of chickpeas
puree until smooth and then serve with
some steamed carrots and peeled cucumber
spears so guys I hope you enjoyed a
little glimpse at some of baby's
favorite on-the-go snacks if you want to
see some more baby or toddler related
content leave me a comment below I'm
always up for your suggestions and you
can also check out the whole playlist
here with all the top picks I've already
covered and until then don't forget to
subscribe to the channel give this video
the thumbs up and I will see you next
time on Abby's kitchen bye